[Music]
this morning on the dish there chefs
business partners and husband and wife
now running their dream restaurant here
in New York
Scott Tyson Ellie and Angie Rito had a
lot in common even before they met they
both grew up in italian-american
families where food was a passion both
became professional chefs and both found
their way to New York's Park Avenue
autumn restaurant where the owners
admire their skill and they admired each
other after tying the knot in Italy the
two opened quality Italian for the
quality branded group now they've
created don angie here in new york chefs
and chips angie rito to Scott Tessa
welcome to the dish thanks for being
here tell us first of all what about
what's on this table um so here we have
our house-made garganelli Gigante with a
broken meatball ragu this is our lasagna
it's kind of a unique presentation on
lasagna it's like a pinwheel style
lasagna we have our stuffed garlic
flatbread with sesame Japanese garlic
chives we have our prosciutto and melon
salad with tamarind hazelnut and mince
and then that's our house salami and
cheese platter on the end there with
savory pizzelle progress and we say
cheers to you and Scott for you this is
a homecoming from what I understand
you've worked here for 10 years so
obviously had to find your way to being
a chef I did I worked here on the eighth
floor I sold advertising for CBS 882
then doing what you're doing now you
know I I did it for I guess almost ten
years and I was just like I don't know I
didn't want to be one of these people
that there was some people that worked
there that were like I've been doing
this for 20 years I can't keep doing
this I didn't want to be that person so
I always loved cooking and I just it
took a couple of classes to see if I
really liked it and then I you know
called my mom one day and I said I think
I'm gonna quit my job and go in and she
was like I think it's the best thing you
can ever do so let's do what's the
secret to your sauce I mean natto has a
lot of husbands and wives can work
together so well and create such amazing
food
I think you know I think it works to our
benefit we we're always sort of like on
the same page like we always kind of
like read each other's minds minds so it
like it helps us in the workplace like
we we're just like always on the same
page we have to communicate minimally
like we're always sort of thinking the
same so you're not throwing things to
each other was done Angie the the dream
was that I mean this new restaurant was
that really what you always wanted
yeah it's it's it's perfect we're super
proud of it I mean it's it's a perfect
size for us you know super and intimate
it has a really warm feeling and it's
just like really I think really is a
good representation of us yeah it
showcases our style you know we kind of
have a different take on
italian-american cuisine what's next for
you then we're working on a cookbook
yeah so we're doing that and we're you
know we're gonna do actually open
quality Italian in Chicago that's great
and then we're looking for some other
opportunities here in New York and some
other cities possibly do some other
things this is all delicious I'm gonna
have you guys both sign our dish and a
question for you both if you could have
this meal with anyone past or present
who would it be
I'm gonna have to go with Julia Child I
think she's such a Wow such a she would
be like a really like cool you know fun
person to share food without however you
so for me it's funny my my grandparents
were a huge influence for me as well as
Angie and you know they never met Angie
and they don't really they don't know
that I actually Michelle so you know I'd
love to have a meal with them and have
them try my food which is like a you
know what's great to have you back Scott
yeah and this for more information on
boscia
yeah that's our website at CBS this
morning calm